how are you I'm doing very well I just I
I was thinking about something today
thinking about you coming on the show
it's almost Halloween a couple of weeks
away from Halloween and I've got to
think there's a lot of pressure on you
around Halloween because when kids ring
your bell and you answer the door it's
Stephen King it's Halloween if you just
give them a Clark bar and say have a
nice evening it's somehow gone arrived
you know what I mean is there pressure
on you to do something kind of crazy or
intense I hate Halloween for that reason
that I just described or if if I could
go to the gulag right on Halloween right
probably would because it used to be
we stayed home and thousands of people
literally would converge on the house
and we gave out I don't know how much
and candy and everything else and we got
to the point where we were actually
thinking about bringing in fog machines
and putting up fake gravestones and
everything and I'm like hold on here a
second I'm turning into the Halloween
Santa Claus right right right
it just became too much about let's all
go to Stephen King's house on Halloween
that's gonna be a really fun thing to do
and I mean Santa Claus isn't real and I
am sort of so Santa Claus might be real
I'm still holding out hope what Santa
Claus out there that could be yeah yeah
hey I'm curious did you you give so many
people nightmares what about you do you
get nightmares and have you've had a
really scary you know dream pass them on
it's sort of like passing a gallstone
right you know just pass them on to
other people only so you begin give
nightmares but you yourself sleep fine
it's more blessed to give than receive
conan and you know it's it's it's a good
thing because obviously some of the
stuff that I've done is fairly twisted
right and it's the kind of thing like if
you had these fantasies in real life as
opposed to my life you'd go to a shrink
right and you'd pay 60 70 $80 for an
hour it's not even a full hour it's a
50-minute hour and
I get paid for these things you know
just it's a great life instead of going
to a therapist you just write it down
and people pay a lot of money to read it
because sometimes they go to the movies
even right well let's talk about what's
up with that because you were one of the
first people to have the idea that a
clown could be a scary figure you
actually in the in in it which became a
movie you wrote about a you created a
homicidal clown it's very effective did
you find clowns scary when you were a
kid well you know as a kid going to the
circus it would be like 12 full-grown
people that would all pile out of a
little tiny car their faces were dead
white their mouths were red as though
they were full of blood they're all
screaming their eyes are huge what's not
to like why were your clowns screaming
so I started to actually look at kids
when I grew up a little bit and I said
you know kids are all terrified of him
and the parents are like aren't the
clowns funny Johnny and then Johnny's
like no get me the hell out of here
we're all crazy because they are
monstrous looking and children are
really afraid of them they do have that
sort of monstrous thing going for them
did you ever have a personal interaction
with a clown that scared you yeah well
not exactly scared me but I was on a I
was on a book tour my first big book
tour and I was on my way home you do
nine ten eleven cities in four days it's
surreal anyway by the time you get done
Cleveland was the last City and the
plane started to pull away from the gate
we're gonna go from Cleveland to
Burlington to Portland where I was going
to get off and drive home plane pulls
away from the gate and then it pulls
back in I'm sitting in first class and
the door opens again and Ronald McDonald
gets on the airplane he's fully dressed
fully clothed oh yeah you know then sits
down next to me because I attract
weirdness you know I'm like a magnet and
and I was so weirded out by that point
after all these you know rubber chicken
dinners and everything else that I
wasn't even surprised
here he is orange hair orange juice the
whole nine yards he sits down next to me
this is years ago plane takes off no
smoking light goes off he pulls out a
packet cants lights up lights up a
cigarette
yeah I can't any orders a gin and tonic
from the stewardess he's sitting there
drinking a gin and tonic smoking I can't
and I I say the only thing I can think
of where did you come from he says
McDonald land
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Yeah right
so I say is this no really where'd you
come from and he had come from
McDonaldland which is a real place in
Chicago and he was going to open a
McDonald's in Burlington Vermont but you
talk about surreal sure 40,000 feet with
Ronald McDonald and you think what if
this plane crashes I'm gonna die next to
a cloud a drunken one too yeah I have to
ask you this cuz it I'm from Boston I
know that you're a been a lifelong Red
Sox fan right and you always I remember
you talking about this you were famous
for saying that you were you were so
convinced that they were never going to
win the World Series you were actually
going to put something that effect on
your gravestone I was gonna have a
gravestone that said not in my lifetime
right but somebody sent me a t-shirt at
the end the last year that said now I
can die in peace that's very nice
that was really nice and I'm gonna wear
that t-shirt but hopefully I won't die
for a long time and I can see that
happen two or three more times it
doesn't look that good this year right
now but yeah well you never know I mean
are you one of those people who's like
happy now that it happened I you know I
don't need it to happen again this year
you don't need the Red Sox to do it this
year you feel that way about your first
sexual experience
what the way it went down yes yeah then
later on when I was in my 50s we uh
the Colorado kid it's gonna be in stores
on October 4th it's a little but it's
powerful yeah what we were just talking
about yeah it's getting dirty fast I'm
going to commercial and this weekend
Stephens going to be at The New Yorker
festival right here in New York City
real thrill thank you so much same here
[Applause]